Бріджет та її сестра Лідія - учасниці тестування вакциною Biontech/Pfizer.
Дітям віком від 5 до 11 років кололи одну третину дорослої дози препарату від ковіду.
Результати клінічних випробувань у США вселили в лікарів надію.
Ефективність вакцини - 91 відсоток.
І користь від вакцинації, на думку експертів, однозначно перевищує пов'язані з нею ризики.
Для мене це очевидно. Ми не хочемо, щоб діти вмирали від ковіду, навіть якщо дітей вмирає набагато менше, ніж дорослих.
І не хочемо, щоб вони потрапляли до реанімації.
У США - найгірші у світі добові показники щодо захворюваності на ковід та летальних випадків.
І лише 57 відсотків населення повністю вакциновані.
У Білому домі прагнуть якомога швидше прищепити дітей до 12 років - їх тут 28 мільйонів.
Переважно це школярі, а навчання наразі недистанційне.
Ми забронювали необхідну кількість вакцини для того, щоб прищепити кожну дитину від 5 до 11 років.
І щойно буде дозвіл управління саннагляду, ми почнемо розвозити мільйони доз країною.
Управління санітарного нагляду за якістю харчових продуктів і медикаментів США
зазвичай прислухається до рекомендацій незалежної експертної групи.
Дозвіл для Biontech для дошкільнят та молодших школярів тут видали раніше, ніж у Євросоюзі.
А от думка батьків неоднозначна. У школах вирують пристрасті навколо щеплення.
Раз у раз спалахують протести, як у Нью-Йорку, на захист вчителів,
яких зобов'язали зробити щеплення під загрозою тимчасового відсторонення від роботи.
Одне з останніх опитувань засвідчило, що 32 відсотки американських батьків не впевнені,
а 24 відсотки - взагалі категорично відкидають вакцинацію дітей.
Лише близько третини опитаних налаштовані зробити щеплення своїм чадам.
Неоднозначне ставлення до щеплень малюків до 12 років й у Німеччині.
Це один з дитячих майданчиків у Берліні.
Новина про те, що вакцина від коронавірусу незабаром буде доступною і для дітей, схвилювала багатьох батьків.
Як вчительці початкових класів мені часто доводиться чути, що школи та дитсадки - це розсадники вірусу.
Але незважаючи на загрозу, я не поспішатиму з вакцинацією.
Моїй молодшій доньці три роки, а старшій скоро виповниться п'ять, але я вирішила почекати зі щепленням від ковіду.
Моєму синові майже три роки, а доньці сім.
Це чудово, що вже незабаром мої діти зможуть отримати імунітет.
Я дуже втомився від цих нескінченних антигенних та ПЛР-тестів.
Протягом останніх місяців компанія Biontech/Pfizer займалася розробкою вакцини для дітей віком від 5 до 11 років.
Попередні результати дослідження виявили високу клінічну ефективність при незначних побічних ефектах.
Берлінський педіатр Якоб Маске радить батькам запастися терпінням
і все ж таки дочекатися офіційного схвалення від Постійної комісії з вакцинації Німеччини.
Ми хочемо заспокоїти батьків. Імунна система дітей багато в чому відрізняється від дорослої, бо вона ще тільки формується.
Діти схильні до безлічі нових для них респіраторних інфекцій,
і це може пояснювати підвищений рівень антитіл у крові - більший, ніж у дорослих.
У заражених ковідом дітей хвороба триває важко лише в рідкісних випадках.
Найчастіше ця інфекція - як легка застуда.
Але головний аргумент на користь вакцинації дітей - це досягнення колективного імунітету,
який завадить новим спалахам коронавірусу і може захистити і нещеплених людей.
Поки що в дослідженні вакцини брало участь ще надто мало дітей.
Я би почекав, поки не з'явиться більше даних і впевненості в тому, що вакцина не має рідкісних побічних ефектів.
Але зрозуміло, що це непогано, коли є певний рівень захисту від ковіду внаслідок вакцинації або після хвороби.
І варто утримуватися від однозначних висловлювань, що хвороба становить низьку загрозу для дітей.
А що про вакцинацію думають самі діти?
Я не проти щеплення, якщо мої батьки підтримають цю ідею.
Так, але тільки, якщо не буде боляче.
Тим часом наприкінці жовтня стало відомо про успішне завершення клінічних випробувань
ще однієї антиковідної вакцини для дітей від компанії Moderna.